RODENTIA Director/Co-Writer Phoebe Jaspé:
I’ve been 24 countries, 4 continents and
I love Scandinavian culture.
Something about me as a filmmaker, I grew
up in Abu Dhabi and I took my A-levels there
and I went to England for University.
With RODENTIA this film I’ve directed it’s
about a CEO turning into a rat.
So the idea came from mainly Franz Kafka’s
METAMORPHOSIS.
My background stems from fine art so I used
to use a lot of oils and canvas and then this
developed into photography.
Film is moving image, so every frame should
actually be like a painting.
It’s very difficult to maintain this because
this takes a lot of time in creating shot
lists.
We designed every single shot in the film
so it’s more to do with aesthetics and it’s
not a feminist film.
The main character was actually based on myself
and of course I’m not that horrible but
it was a part of me that I wanted to destroy.
The best way to express your negative traits
is though an art form and that’s the only
way to have a release and of course to get
rid of depression or anxiety or manic psychosis
which is what my feature film is about, is
based on a 10-day manic psychosis episode,
more on that later.
So we wanted to explore in an authentic way
how does it feel becoming a rat.
And losing your beauty is a huge theme in
the film and so is disfigurement.
So if you combine disfigurement with traditional
beauty it creates a sort of duality in the
picture and I think that’s quite important
to explore.
Actor Fabian Bolin: “I’m getting some
hair attached to my back by a special fx make-up
artist.”
Prop Maker and Special Makeup Effects Artist,
Jayne Hyman: “I’m just applying some hair,
this is crepe hair, it’s like a theatrical
hair that for special fx make-up.”
Actor Fabian Bolin: “I focus on more about
the character than the animal.
I’m playing a rat, you know.
And it takes quite a lot to get that realistically
with the movement and everything to focus
on and it helps not to bother and worry about
the mask or something falling off and stuff
like that.”
Adam Pearson has worked with Scarlett Johansson
in the film UNDER THE SKIN and UNDER THE SKIN
is directed by Jonathan Glazer.
And Jonathan Glazer directed that famous Guinness
horse advertising campaign.
I wanted to find an actor that’s quite beautiful
and I wanted them to be together on set during
the office scene because it creates some sort
of duality when opposites interact with each
other you kind of feel a sense of completion
because a disfigured man with a beautiful
model you kind of feel like they belong to
each other and that’s what we tried to create
in that specific office scene.
Also Fabian Bolin is a method actor, so he
practiced how to actually behave like an animal.
On set we actually called him by his character’s
name rather than his real name.
I think method acting is definitely important
when you actually want to embody a character
in a film.
Another interesting thing is we picked Fabian
Bolin as the main actor.
He is Swedish and Brazilian and we picked
him out of 200 applicants.
Swedish people tend to have that sort of villain
type of look.
And we can see it Bill Skarsgård and we can
see it in that CTO, the guy in MR.
ROBOT.
But Swedish people really the villains that
I like.
Well, if you want to check the film out it’s
in the link in the description.
I’m still connected to companies especially
3-D animation and I’m also really into creating
music videos.
If you are a musician or artist in Scandinavia
or anywhere in Europe I would love to work
with you.
And I’ve filmed 5 music videos in Iceland
and I really enjoy it.
“What the f?
What the f?”